good character is not formed in a week
or a month
it is created little by little
day by day protracted and patient effort
is needed
the unexamined life is not worth living
I never did anything worth doing by
accident
nor did any of my inventions come by
accident they came by work
it is during our darkest moments that we
must Focus to see the light
the ideal man Bears the accidents of
life with dignity and Grace
making the best of circumstances
we cannot live better than in seeking to
become better
The Secret Of Happiness you see is not
found in seeking more but in developing
the capacity to enjoy less
would you leave behind is not what is
engraved in stone monuments
but what is woven into the lives of
others
you will never do anything in this world
without courage
it is the greatest quality of the Mind
next to honor
people are like dirt
they can either nourish you and help you
grow as a person
or they can stunt your growth and make
you wilt and die
happy is the man who has broken the
chains which hurt the mind and has given
up worrying once and for all
waste no more time arguing about what a
good man should be
one
do not say little in many words but a
great deal in few
good actions give strength to ourselves
and Inspire good actions in others
difficulties strengthen the mind as
labor does the body
happiness and freedom begin with one
principle
some things are within your control and
some are not
we can easily forgive a child who's
Afraid of the Dark
the real tragedy of life is when men are
afraid of the light
employ your time in improving yourself
by other men's writings
so that you shall gain easily what
others have labored hard for
the only true wisdom is in knowing that
you know nothing
moral Excellence comes about as a result
of habit
we become just by doing just acts
temper it by doing temperate Acts
Brave by doing Brave Acts
the roots of Education are bitter
fruit is sweet
beware the barrenness of a busy life
no man has the right to be an amateur in
the matter of physical training
it is a shame for a man to grow old
without seeing the beauty and strength
in which his body is capable
it is not living that matters
but living rightly